MALE SPEAKER: So good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to another Talks
at Google event.
So thank you all for
joining us today.
Today, we're very pleased to
host paleoanthropologist and
National Geographic adventurer
Lee Berger.
Dr. Berger leads the
paleoanthropology research
group at the University
of Witwatersrand
down in South Africa.
And among his many discoveries
include the
Australopithecus sediba.
Again, I guess clearly, Latin
was not my strong suit.
Were it written in French, it
would have been better.
And also his work on the Taung
Bird of Prey hypothesis.
Dr. Berger, he's taking a break
from his research in
South Africa to tour on his
latest book, which is actually
entitled "The Skull on the
Rock." It is a book intended
for wide audience that
chronicles his discovery of
the recent human ancestor
skeletons and also his
integration with Google
Earth, of all things.
He uses our tools to advance the
field and also to advance
our knowledge of
human history.
So please join me in welcoming
Lee to Google.
LEE BERGER: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I just have to say that, on
behalf of pretty much the
entirety of the scientific
community, we probably owe
more to your organization as an
open access and open window
into new areas of science
than almost any
other on the internet.
That includes the normal things
you think of, like
Google Earth and Google Scholar,
that we depend on now
almost completely, as scientists
but also just
[? google-ine, ?]
which is a lot of fun.
This sort of story that I'm
going to tell you has a lot of
those components in it.
I'm going to tell you
a story about a
discovery in human origins.
I'm a paleoanthropologist.
I look for early human
ancestors.
I actually look for the
rarest sought-after
objects on the planet.
I'm in a field of science that
actually probably has more
scientists in it than it does
objects that we study.
There are literally just a few
thousand of these incredibly
precious objects.
Most of them are just fragments,
tiny little bits
and pieces.
About 80% of the record of
human origins in Africa
represents isolated teeth.
The remaining, say, 18% of that
represents little bits
and pieces of post-cranial
bones, of which we almost had
no complete elements
from the neck down.
Those skulls and stuff you see
on "National Geographic" and
such, those are incredibly
rare,
numbering just a few dozen.
But this story is a story of
some success in discovery.
And while parts of it may seem
like a eureka moment and a
sort of what wondrous luck, like
many great discoveries
that happen, it begins
in failure.
In the late 1990s, I was
privileged enough to win the
first National Geographic
Prize for Research and
Exploration.
When I went to receive that
medal in Washington, I was
hauled up into those magnificent
offices up on the
top floor of National
Geographic, sat across from
Gilbert Grosvenor, the then
CEO, and Bill Allen, the
powerful editor of
the magazine.
And they said something that I
hope all of you hear some time
in your life.
They said to me, you can have
anything you want, any amount
of money you want, to do
anything you want.
Now, they of course
meant that within
some reason, I presumed.
But I knew exactly what
I wanted to do.
I wanted to apply technology
to the search for these
incredibly rare fossils and the
sites that they come from.
And the reason I wanted to do
that so badly around 1997 was
a series of technological events
that occurred at that
time that made it
more accessible.
One was the readily available
handheld GPS.
Now, things like the highly
expensive Trimble GPS had on
the box that it could get you
to within the remarkable
distance of something like 15
meters on planet Earth.
And it cost thousands
and thousands of
dollars to do that.
The other thing that happened at
that time was that NASA had
released its digital
satellite images.
And I could afford down to the
30 meter pixels that they had.
And I think most of you would
remember back in those times,
that those sheets cost in the
neighborhood of $10,000 apiece
for one sheet.
And we had to get new computers
at my university to
even run them.
I think they were something
impossible like 300 or 400
megabytes a file that we had
to run at that time.
But there I received this grant
to go do this expedition
utilizing this technology.
And I set off across
southern Africa.
But also, concentrated some of
my work in an area right
outside of Johannesburg, South
Africa, that's now called the
Cradle of Humankind, a UNESCO
World Heritage site.
It wasn't then.
It was a dolomitic limestone
area that stretched for about
60 kilometers in length
and about 10 in width.
And from that area, which is
arguably the most explored
area on planet Earth for these
early hominid fossils,
continuously since 1935, had
come some of the most
fantastic fossils, but from
a tiny number of sites.
By that time, there'd only been
about 14 fossil-bearing
sites for these early
human fossils.
But only about four of them were
considered really of any
serious value.
So it was in that environment
of looking for these things
that I began to utilize
this technology--
not only do the first GPS
coordinates of sites, because
we didn't have them.
They were all map coordinates
prior to that.
But also to find new sites.
And over a three-year period,
I did find new
sites in the area.
I managed to find four new
fossil sites in that area.
I know that doesn't sound like
a huge number, but remember
the context of only knowing
of 14 fossil sites.
And remember that it was the
most explored area on planet
Earth for these very things.
I found an additional 30 caves
that were undocumented.
We had about 30 non-fossil
bearing case
documented in that area.
And I thought this
was pretty good.
And so as we moved into the
late '90s and early 21st
century, I began digging some
of these new sites, with the
hopes of them producing
some of these
extraordinarily rare fossils.
Now, let me tell you just
how important even
single finds are.
When I first went to Africa,
in 1991, I found two fossil
hominid teeth, two single
teeth, at a site called
Gladysvale, right in the
middle of this area.
And it made "National
Geographic" magazine.
Can you imagine?
It was the first new
site in 48 years.
And that's the kind of a rarity
that people like me
deal with in their day-to
day search.
So as I began to explore these
sites, I did find a few bits
and pieces, which made
me pretty happy.
But I did not find anything
extraordinary by the time we
moved into the early
21st century.
Now having said that, I have
to qualify that most of the
people that do what I do will
never find what we seek.
Can you imagine going into a
field of science where there's
probably a 99.9% chance that
you will never discover a
single element of one of these
early hominids in the wild?
You literally can count the
scientists who've actually
physically discovered these in
Africa on two hands and have
some fingers left over
when you do that.
So I did this digging.
But I work at a university.
And for anyone who's ever worked
in the academic or
university environment,
universities live off things
like "Nature" and "Science"
papers,
these high-impact papers.
And finding little bits
and scraps wasn't
getting us into those.
And as we reached about 2005,
2006, my university made the
decision to begin moving away
from my exploration unit that
I had established to search for
these sites and move into
an area of science driven
solely by technology, to
replace that.
I was going to be effectively
retrenched.
They couldn't, of course.
I was a tenured professor
by the time.
But they were moving in
this new direction.
Because a lot of critical things
that I don't have to
explain to this audience were
happening at that period.
Processing power was becoming
enormous and readily available.
Computers--
things like geometric,
morphometric, the ability to
handle these big data sets
that were produced by CT
scans, three-dimensional
exercises,
were coming into vogue.
That's what was getting on
the cover of "Nature" and
"Science." And that's where my
university started moving.
They started searching
for a director.
And eventually in 2007, they
actually found someone to
effectively replace me, a young
man who had been my
former student.
I think some of you in
technology will sympathize a
little bit with that
sort of transition
that occurs very quickly.
But it was an exciting period.
We bought equipment.
We bought tons of these
new computers,
very expensive software.
And we even started bringing
in a whole host of young
people to start building a lab
that no longer really focused
its full energy on finding new
fossils, but studying those
that had been discovered over
the past 70 or 80 years.
It was going to be a
retrospective thing as we
moved into this new world.
And there I found myself, in
December period of 2007,
surfing the web, looking
for a new life.
I was kind of looking for where
I would find myself in
the future, with all of the kind
of things I've explained.
And it was at that moment that
I became the last human being
on Earth to discover
Google Earth.
Now, as most of you did, what
did everyone do when they
first discovered Google Earth,
a long time before I did?
AUDIENCE: Look at your house.
LEE BERGER: You look at your
own house, to see if you're
lying naked by the
swimming pool.
I wasn't.
Then you look at places that
are familiar to you.
And sometime in that journey,
you find that amazing white
box there on the left-hand
side that has those GPS
coordinates that you
can stick in.
And if you've got some,
you stick them in.
And you fly out of outer space,
right to this singular
fantastic point.
Well, I had some of the most
expensively obtained GPS
coordinates on the planet.
And I eagerly put the
first ones in.
And it zoomed in from outer
space in that great zoom in--
and landed on nothing.
The second one, nothing.
The third one, nothing.
I had useless GPS coordinates.
It did not take me long
to google why they
were useless, of course.
The United States government had
owned those satellites in
the late 1990s.
They'd put deliberate
error into them.
And that, combined with the
error in my relatively
primitive handheld GPSes,
created a form of a
compounding error.
And all of my data points were
off by dozens, if not
hundreds, of meters.
They were useless.
I'd spent three years of my
life and several thousand
dollars of National Geographic's
money.
And I was sad for a while.
I was probably most sad about
having to call up National
Geographic and explain this.
And so I spent January,
February, and March moving the
points from their incorrect
position to
their correct position.
Because I could actually
see the sites that
I intended to do.
Amazingly, the area where I'd
concentrated my research had
5-meter resolution on
Google at that time.
And I could see the sites.
I knew the area very well.
And I can actually see
the physical sites.
And it was in the process of
moving those dots from the
wrong place to the right place
that I began to discover
something amazing.
I first started thinking I saw
patterns in the distribution
of these various caves and
various fossil sites.
It seemed that the fossil
sites seemed to cluster
together in unusual ways.
And I also learned through
correcting that error what a
cave site and then what a fossil
site looked like from
outer space.
And I begin to think that,
if that's a cave, this
looks like a cave.
But I knew it couldn't be.
I had walked over that
area over the last 17
years prior to that.
Everybody, every big name
in paleoanthropology has
explored this area.
I knew there was nothing
to find.
But by March of that year, it
bothered me enough that I
created a list of targets.
And I did something
very human.
I went as far away within this
region as I could get from the
site of Gladysvale, where I'd
spent the last 17 years
looking for these things.
Because I knew there
was nothing there.
I knew that area as well
as my own backyard.
And so I moved away from there,
actually into a little
town called Krugersdorp,
actually the city limits, with
this list of first targets.
And on my first day out in
March, I found 21 new sites.
21 sites that no scientist
had ever seen before.
By July of that year, I'd found
600 new sites, that no
scientist had put a pin on,
40 new fossil sites.
So we went from effectively,
say, 17 or 18 fossil sites
that we knew of to well over 70
of them, in just a matter
of moments.
It was an incredible,
incredible period for discovery.
Everyone was very excited.
Because suddenly, we had these
resources in front of us, this
long potential, that could last
decades, hundreds of years.
And I truly thought that
that was going to be my
contribution to this field,
this discovery of
this mass of resources.
When by the end of July, I
moved back into the area
around Gladysvale.
And of course, immediately
I began finding
sites, all in the area.
I had missed them.
They'd been right in
front of my eyes.
And the 1st of August, I moved
into the area that you're
about to see, as this camera
zooms up, an area that I knew
I wasn't going to find anything
in, even by that age.
Because down in this valley,
back in the late 1990s when I
was doing that National
Geographic expedition, I had
found one of those four
fossil sites.
It was 1 kilometer away from
Gladysvale, one and a half
hills away from where I had
spent the last 17 years.
And I had been on this road that
runs in here literally
hundreds of times over
the last 17 years.
However, I saw these targets,
which you see being
highlighted right now.
And by that time, I suspected
that that was what caves and
potential fossil-bearing
caves looked like.
So I drove down this road
with my dog Tao.
And as I got to right here, I
realized that I was going to
make a discovery of at least
some cave sites.
Because there was an old
lime-miners' trackway, that
somehow all of us had missed,
running right up to this
particular little
grove of trees.
I heard you all gasp
when you saw that.
I know.
But the reason I gasped when I
saw that is it shouldn't have
been there.
Any time you see a grove of
trees like this, what you're
actually seeing is a disturbed
area of soil.
It means that this dolomitic
terrain, which is
2.6-billion-year-old limestone,
is very tough for
trees to grow in.
When you see clusters like
this, particularly of two
types of trees, white stinkwood
and wild olives--
it's the light one and the dark
one there-- you know that
there's disturbed or collapsed
systems underneath.
I walked into that, and I
saw this shocking thing.
No, you don't have to gasp all
at once when you see that.
What that was was a tiny little
hole in the middle of
that grove of trees.
That hole is about 2 by
2 and 1/2 meters.
It was very unusual.
It was a hole dug by
the lime miners.
They'd found it.
They know there was a collapsed
cave there.
They put in three drill holes
and three dynamite blasts.
They'd blown up some rock in a
typical way, in their search
for lime in these caves.
But they'd done something then
I had not seen before.
They left it alone.
And I'd almost never
seen that.
I turned the first rock
over that I came to.
And there was an antelope
humerus, an arm bone, sticking
in this concrete-like
rock infill.
I was stunned.
I was less than a kilometer
from where I'd
spent the last 17 years.
I was less than 200 meters
from where I'd found
a site in the 1990s.
So I had been there.
And I could tell no other
scientist had been there,
because we leave tells.
We pile little rocks together.
We sort the things when
we find them.
But I was on a mapping
expedition.
So I looked around.
I saw there were
other fossils.
And I took that terrible
picture.
I took an accurate GPS
coordinate, some notes, and
walked up the hill and
found 46 new caves.
46 caves in this little hidden
valley that no scientist had
seen before, in the center of
the most explored area on
planet Earth for those
very objects.
I was stunned.
I went back to the lab.
And we'd had a tragedy just a
couple of weeks before this.
The young man who was going to
come and take over my position
and change this whole
organization into this
high-tech organization was
killed in a motorcycle
accident in London.
And we were devastated because
we were rudderless.
We'd already hired people.
We'd spent enormous amounts
reequipping
to go in this direction.
And a young man came into
my office, a young
Kenyan named Job Kibii.
And he said, would I take over
his postdoctoral supervision?
Charlie was going to be his
postdoctoral supervisor.
And I said, no, Job, I won't.
You're a lab guy.
I'm a field guy.
I can't teach you that.
But I've just found this site.
And if you want to learn to be
a field guy, let's go out.
Let's take a look at this site
and see what it has to offer.
And so we went back out there.
On the 15th of August, Job,
myself, my then nine-year-old
son Matthew, and my dog Tao
went back to that site,
walked up to it.
And as we walked up, I told them
how I'd discovered it, in
much the way I've
just told you.
We got to the edge
of this pit.
We were looking down into it.
And I said, OK, guys,
go find fossils.
If you find any fossils,
give me a call.
I'll come and identify them.
And let's see what
the site has.
And with that, Matthew
and Tao are gone.
This is a huge game reserve.
There's leopards and giraffe
and zebra and
antelopes and stuff.
And I think he's off
to chase some--
I'll see him at lunch time.
So I turned to Job.
And I said, I bet the lime
miners left this alone,
because they did the
same thing I did.
They found this site first,
in the bottom of the hill.
They start digging it.
So the foreman walks up the hill
or something and sees all
these other caves.
He comes back.
They blast.
Nothing really looks good.
They take up, and they had
destroyed every single one of
those other caves, just
destroyed them.
And as I finish saying
that, Matthew said,
Dad, I found a fossil.
Matthew was 15 meters off
the site, in high grass.
And I almost didn't
go and look.
I almost didn't go and look
because I knew absolutely what
Matthew had found.
Matthew had found an
antelope fossil.
Because for every one of these
early human ancestors that we
find, every one piece, we find
250,000 antelope fossils.
But he's my nine-year-old son.
And like you, you all want to
encourage fossil hunting.
So I wandered over to him.
I got about 5 meters away,
and I saw this.
And I knew that his
and my life were
going to change forever.
Because he was holding
that little block.
This was taken moments after
that, in that high grass.
You can see there was nothing
else around it.
He was sitting at the base of
a lightning-struck tree.
But what I saw sticking out of
the side of that rock from 5
meters away was this.
Now I got you to gasp.
No one gasped.
I knew exactly what that was.
That was an early
human clavicle.
That's this bone right here.
It's your collarbone
right here.
And I knew instantly.
They're really easy
to identify.
Firstly, only a few mammals
have them in Africa.
Bats have them because
they fly.
It was too big.
Moles have them, because
they dig.
It was too big.
And primates have them.
And only amongst primates do
you ever see this very
characteristic S-shape,
a sigmoid curvature.
And at that particular moment in
time, I happened to be the
only world's expert on
hominid clavicles.
I'd done my PhD on them.
I did my PhD on them because
they were so rare that there
were only bits and pieces
of fragments left.
I in fact did my PhD on the
clavicle, the proximal
humerus, and the scapula.
Because no one else wanted to,
because we didn't have any in
the fossil record.
And I was looking at one.
Matthew says I cursed.
I don't believe that.
But I took the rock and did
what any of you would do.
What else could this be?
And I turned it over and
sticking out of the
back of it was this.
And that was completely
unmistakable.
That is the lower jaw and
a canine, maybe the most
identifiable tooth, in a jaw
of a hominid, sticking out.
And I could see other bones.
And then I was very excited.
I might have actually
cursed then.
Because I knew that I had the
real possibility of holding in
my hand what Matthew had found,
a partial skeleton.
And at that point, there had
been approximately seven found
in all of history from
anywhere, in Africa.
You would know some
of their names--
Lucy, the Turkana Boy, Little
Foot, the Dikika
child, Lucy's child.
And then the remaining two
are so fragmentary,
they only have numbers.
That is any piece of a head,
associated with any piece of a
body, of a single individual.
We're very generous with the
definition of partial skeletons.
And I was probably
holding one.
I called the South African
Heritage Resource Agency,
because there's actually cell
phone coverage at the site, to
get permission to take it out.
We got it back to the lab,
this concrete-like rock.
My preparator started
preparing it.
Within days, we realized Matthew
had found a skeleton.
And we knew a lot about
it almost instantly.
We could see that it
had this jaw in it.
And it was a child, probably
about 11 to
12, 13 years of age.
Its third molar wasn't
erupted.
Its limbs had not finished
growing.
We could see the growth lines,
the unfused epiphyses.
It was hugely exciting.
It was the upper part
of a child.
It was a magnificent moment.
There was much rejoicing
at the Institute.
You can literally build
institutes around a discovery
like this, and ours.
So I had to wait until I had
heard that I was going to
actually get the permit
to work the site.
On September 3, I got the call
that I would get the permit.
On September 4, we all went back
to that site, everybody
from my university that had
a PhD or master's in
paleoanthropology, biological
anthropology, archaeology, or
who liked dogs, went
back to the site.
Because as I told you, we
don't find these things.
We spend our lives not
discovering them.
And I think everybody there--
14 of us went--
had the idea that if a
nine-year-old can do it in a
minute and a half, this
is our moment.
Three hours after arriving
there, we had found nothing
that we could definitively
call a hominid.
In and out of that hole-- you
can see how tiny it was--
we couldn't find anything
that seemed to
associate with this block.
We couldn't put it
back in place.
We couldn't find anything that
we could definitively say
wasn't an antelope
or something.
And we were devastated.
Now, in South Africa, I come
from a sort of British
culture, an English
culture there.
So when times are really
bad in that culture,
we break for tea.
And so we did break for tea.
We went, sat under the tree.
And I walked back over
to this pit.
And I stood there, staring
down into that hole.
And I was trying to reconstruct
that moment, maybe
100, 110 years ago.
A blast must have
just gone off.
The rocks are scattered
out here.
And how could a rock get from in
here to over there, back in
the high grass where Matthew
had found it?
And I began to have that
hideously ugly feeling that
maybe this didn't
come from here.
What if that rock had just
fallen off of an old ox wagon
or something, coming from one
of those other 46 caves that
had been destroyed?
And I was devastated.
And as I was staring at that,
visualizing that moment, the
sun came up so it shined just
along the back of that.
And there, sticking out of the
wall, the wall that we had all
been next to dozens of times,
was a proximal humerus of an
early human, sticking
right out the wall.
Remember, I did my
PhD on them.
I know what they look like.
I didn't say anything.
No, I climbed down
into the hole.
I walked towards it.
I got about a meter and
a half away from it.
And I realized that the scapula,
the shoulder blade,
was sitting in articulation.
I still didn't say anything.
I put my hand on the wall.
And two hominid teeth
were lying loose and
fell out into my hand.
Then I said something.
And everyone rushed
down in there.
We were hugely excited.
We suddenly realized that our
paradigm had been wrong.
Because lying all around us were
blocks like this, with
actually the proximal femur.
We had been anticipating
failure, when in fact, we were
sitting on a treasure trove.
Well, that has changed
everything.
From that extraordinary
experience, I didn't realize
that what I was looking at
was not the skeleton
that Matthew had found.
It was a second skeleton.
Because never before in all of
history had two skeletons been
found in the same place.
The one I found, we knew
immediately, after we took it
back to the lab and begin to
prepare it out, was actually
an adult skeleton.
It had a fused epiphyses.
So I could see that it was
an older individual.
It would turn out to later be
a female, an adult female.
We would later find Matthew's
skeleton lying just 50
centimeters above
that position.
And so this little site, in
the past several years--
that I would eventually call
Malapa, which means my home in
the Sotho language--
has produced extraordinary
results.
And also, we've been very
fortunate because we've
discovered at a time where
we've been able to apply
extraordinary technology
to it.
This looks like a
video to you.
It's not a video.
It's actually 21 million
three-dimensional coordinates,
each accurate to about a
millimeter and a half on
planet Earth, that we can
actually take and place every
find back into context.
If we'd found it six years
ago, we could not have
achieved that sort of technology
application.
In April of 2010, my team and
I announced that these
skeletons were actually a new
species of early human.
We did it in a special
edition of "Science."
And of course, my colleagues
all forced me
to show this image.
Because for scientists, getting
your fossil on the
cover of "Science" is like for a
rock star being on the cover
of "Rolling Stone." So they
forced me to put this up here.
But the preservation
is extraordinary.
At that time, we had
these skeletons.
We named a new species, called
Australopithecus sediba.
Australopithecus is
the genus name.
We had to accept an already
existing one that we felt it
associated with.
"Sediba" means source or well
spring or natural spring.
And you'll hear why we named
that in just a moment.
As incomplete as those look at
that time, they were both
independently the most complete
early hominids that
had ever been discovered in
the history of science.
Both more complete than the
famous Lucy fossil.
The site would yield
preservation that we could not
even imagine just
a few years ago.
I hope you can see the quality
of the musculature, the
preservation of that bone, that
we would then know was
1.977 to 1.98 million
years old.
So you're looking at a
2-million-year-old fossil.
That is the most complete early
hominid skull that has
almost certainly ever
been found.
There is amazing preservation
that goes
beyond the bone there.
We have found organic
preservation there.
Some of you might have seen, we
announced the discovery of
calculus and tartar on the teeth
just a few months ago,
in the journal "Nature." And
inside of that were food
particulates.
So never again will a scientist
like me guess at
what they ate.
We know that they ate fruits and
nuts and seeds, like you
would expect.
They also ate bark,
interestingly.
That isn't that uncommon.
That's the kind of thing
that actually happens.
But it's that level of
preservation that's
extraordinary.
We may have even found skin.
We may have even found
early hominid skin.
Watch this space early
next year.
Last year, we published more of
this material in "Science,"
in another special edition,
more of the
extraordinary fossils.
And these skeletons became
then works in progress.
The female on the left, you
can see is remarkably
complete, with critical bones
that we had never before seen
in the fossil record.
He looks pretty incomplete,
only at about 40%.
My wife, who is a medical
doctor, a radiologist in fact,
is just finishing her PhD in
paleoanthropology now.
I guess so she had something
to talk about
over the dinner table.
But she did it on scanning
the blocks in rocks.
And in doing that, the very last
block that she scanned a
few months ago had
the remainder of
his skeleton in it.
So we now know that he will be
almost completely complete,
something unprecedented at
that time depth, really
unprecedented out of the last
few thousand years.
They don't look anything
like they should.
Sediba is bizarre.
It could be because they are so
complete that we had been
misreading the rest
of the record.
That is, we'd been
underestimating things like
limb length and the
shape of them.
Or it may be that we have found
truly one of the most
mosaic, transitional fossils,
and unexpected species that
ever existed in that critical
time period.
Because at that moment, it's
when we transitioned from
these early australopithecines
like Lucy to our genus, Homo.
They have incredibly
long arms.
Here, you can see the arm
of a chimpanzee on
the left-hand side.
In the middle is sediba.
That is a pygmy.
And they're all scaled
to the same size.
You can see sediba has
long, ape-like arms.
The moment we had that
discovered, we knew exactly
what the hand would be.
Because that is the
arm of a climber.
And we knew that the hand would
be long, with curved
phalanges for climbing, because
that's what other
australopithecines look like.
That's what apes look like.
Except the hand was sitting at
the end of that arm, and it
didn't look anything
like that.
That's the most human-like
hand that has ever been
discovered out of Homo sapiens
and Neanderthals.
We don't have any Homo erectus
hands, so we don't know what
they look like.
But it is not an
australopithecine hand.
In fact, that hand at 2 million
years is more advanced
than the hand of Homo habilis,
which was the first early
member of new species put into
that genus, but is almost
300,000 to 400,000 years
younger than this.
That's an extraordinary thing.
How can you have a derived,
advanced hand, sitting on this
end of this ape-like arm?
The answer is, we don't know.
But if you ever wonder--
you know, people go, well, how
can you tell from just a bit
or a piece, that it really
is a biped or it's
a human-like ancestor?
Here's a good example.
This is sediba's upper limb.
You're going to see this part
published very shortly.
But you can see how
long it is.
This is a chimpanzee.
But you can see how the scapula
is shaped broad and
wide at the base, in order to
accommodate bipedalism.
And what is most striking is
the difference between the
hand morphology here, with the
short, long-thumbed hand of a
human, and the long, curved
hand of an ape.
The pelvis and other
parts of the
anatomy are equally bizarre.
This is Lucy's pelvis
in the middle.
That's what it should have
looked like, because the
cranial capacity of sediba is
only 420 cubic centimeters.
That's the size of a grapefruit,
if you imagine.
It's amongst the smallest of
any australopithecine.
And we had thought that the
reason australopithecines had
these wide, stable pelvises
was because they could.
Humans have a tall, broad
pelvis, in order to have a
sort of destabilized
bipedalism.
It actually seems
disadvantageous.
We developed an entire thing.
Read a textbook.
It's called the obstetric
hypothesis.
The idea that the reason the
human pelvis is inefficient
like that is because we
needed to give birth
to big-brained babies.
Sediba single-handedly proves
that's not true.
Every textbook's going to
have to be rewritten.
Because it has a human-like
pelvis, but this incredibly,
incredibly tiny brain.
We can even tell things like
the female had had a child.
She has indications of having
the stress marks, having the
child and that.
And other amazing things, like
they have sex differences in
the pelvis.
We know a lot about the site.
We know the site existed about
30 to 50 meters underground 2
million years ago.
It was some sort of submerged
sediment trap, in a pool of
water supersaturated with
calcium carbonate.
And that these hominids
were falling in there.
They actually have evidence that
they'd broken their arms.
He's broken both of
his arms at the
surgical neck of the humerus.
She seems to have dislocated
her right arm as she fell,
possibly sticking it out.
And they are there with
many other animals.
They're there with antelopes.
They're there with saber-toothed
cats.
They're there with hyenas,
down to little
mice, insects, birds.
None of them have
been scavenged.
So whatever the situation that
they found themselves in was
so protective that it prevented
scavengers from
getting to them.
They were buried very quickly
and cemented, like Jimmy Hoffa
being poured into concrete.
And that's why we have this
extraordinary, remarkable situation.
Every animal we find is the most
complete that has ever
been discovered in the history
of Plio-Pleistocene
paleontology on the continent
of Africa.
We're able to do, because of
their completeness, fairly
remarkable reconstructions.
This is Karabo in the middle.
This is Lucy here.
And this is Turkana Boy, a
Homo erectus that's about
400,000 years younger.
You can see the lengthening
of the legs, but still the
maintenance of an abnormally
long arm, but not an increase
in the head.
This is a remarkably complex
transition that we as a field
of science did not expect.
And we don't know what
to do with it.
As I said, it sits at a critical
time period, right at
the transition between this
group of australopithecines
and whatever comes next.
We don't know whether this is
that transition or not because
it's so unexpected.
We probably will find
out eventually.
Because the skeletons I'm
showing you are not alone.
They are there with many
other individuals.
We have found at least four
other skeletons in a company.
At least two infants, an adult,
and at least another
juvenile, at least we haven't
excavated yet.
We are going to see from this
site potentially the most
extraordinary look at a
population of early humans
that anyone has ever seen.
We've also been able to apply
really cool technology to it.
You may have noticed that
the rock was still left
underneath the skull.
That's my team's gift to future
scientists, 100 years,
1,000 years, 10,000
years from now.
That's the record of
where we found them
as technology improved.
And the reason I can afford to
leave that time capsule for
future generations of scientists
is that I can make
the rock disappear now.
I can then take a skull out.
I can take the various pieces
that we find in the rock.
I can put them back together.
And then I can, of course,
make it invisible.
And yes, what you're
seeing there is in
fact a fossil brain.
You may wonder, how can you
have a 2-million-year-old
fossil brain?
Well, the answer to that is
that every time your heart
beats, it pounds out effectively
an image of the
exterior of your brain on the
inside of your skull.
By taking this scanning
technology, we can pass
through, reverse that image, and
of course create a replica
of sediba's skull.
And it, of course, doesn't look
like what it should, just
like the rest of its anatomy.
It has a 420 cubic
centimeter brain.
But as you can see from this,
it's bilaterally asymmetric.
That's an advanced trait,
very similar to ours.
And also, if you're very careful
in looking, you will
see that as this turns around,
it has a bulge in this area,
which is called Broca's
area, which is often
associated with language.
So there appear to be some
changes, reorganization going
on, before encephalization,
before brain size increase.
That's got to be
rewritten, too.
Because that was completely
unexpected from
our previous record.
You can see also, we can do cool
things like look at the
developmental age, look at
various parts of the interior
structure, that we just didn't
have the capacity until very
recently to do.
This is the most expensive
picture you will ever see
produced in your life.
I don't care what you have
on your walls at home.
This machine cost 6.5 billion
euros to produce this.
It's a synchrotron--
two weeks in front of that to
create this image, which is a
0.075 micron reproduction of
that skull, the most accurate
reproduction passing through
it ever done
for an early hominid.
It's allowing us to look right
down to the basic building
structure of these.
We can actually look down to
the point of looking at the
daily incremental growth
lines in teeth.
So you will know eventually, how
old that little child was,
to within nine days of his
death, 2 million years ago.
That's pretty cool.
So what did I learn
from all this?
And what I'm going to
leave you with.
Well, a couple of things
that I would like to
leave you with here.
One is that I think that a lot
of people out there in the
real world, and particularly
children, feel that all the
cool stuff has been
discovered.
That basically what we will do
out there in the natural world
is follow in the footsteps
of great explorers.
That we've explored this
planet over the
last 300 or 400 years.
We've set foot on it.
We've climbed all
the mountains.
If you're going to get in
"National Geographic," you
have to climb naked up the south
side of Everest with a
dead parrot on your shoulder
if anyone's
going to pay attention.
That if you're going to make big
contributions in business
or engineering or [? science, ?]
it is going to
be incremental in its growth,
maybe even in software
engineering or the internet and
such as that, because it's
all been laid out.
What this discovery says
is that is not true.
Sitting there in the middle of
the most explored area on
planet Earth for these very
objects, so easy that a
nine-year-old could see it,
was not only just another
piece of one of these, but maybe
the best that have ever
been discovered to date.
That means, absolutely,
that we have not
explored this planet.
We may have walked all over
every square inch of its
surface, but we have
not seen it.
What is now going to happen is
that this generation is going
to be privileged enough to
utilize technology, crowd
sourcing, to actually see and
understand what we've been
stepping on this entire time.
The second thing that comes out
of this is that we humans
have a tremendous sense
of backyard syndrome.
You all know what backyard
syndrome is?
Backyard syndrome is this.
If I do an exercise with you,
I say, look around this room
that we're sitting
in right now.
Pay special attention to it.
And then we walk outside
to that coffee shop.
And I say, OK, I want you
to draw this room.
And I want you to draw your
backyard, or your living room,
or your kitchen, something
you're
intimately familiar with.
You will do a better job of
drawing this room than you
will your backyard.
Because your backyard is
actually, in your brain, an
amalgamation of all your
experiences with it.
It looks like what your backyard
looked like two years
ago to the present.
It's why you will find a
Post-it note on your
refrigerator from two years
ago, reminding you to do
something you didn't do.
Because that's how
our brain works.
We're protected from the normal
until there are gross
differences that are seen.
There was a fossil in a site
sitting in the middle of the
most explored area on planet
Earth by scientists, by people
looking for these very things,
and we missed it.
My colleagues and I had
backyard syndrome.
It took the eyes of a child
who had no expectation of
non-discovery to actually
find that first piece.
This has been an extraordinary
situation for us.
It's been a humbling experience
for my team.
I went from an organization that
was going to be closed to
an organization with more
than 100 scientists
from around the world.
We represent one of the single
largest focused scientific
projects on the planet.
All in the short space of
time, all based upon the
discovery by a nine-year-old
of a clavicle.
And that's why, if some people
would ask why we've written
things like this children's
book first, because it did
touch children.
This idea that first, they
could contribute.
They could participate in big
science, and it isn't just a
fluke of discovery.
It's not just that Matthew said,
Dad, I found a fossil,
with no knowledge.
He saw something different.
Remember that the rest of us had
to spend hours and hours
to actually gain that childhood
phenomenon.
So ladies and gentlemen, it has
been a privilege to talk
to you here at Google.
You, as I said at the beginning
of this, have done
more for the natural sciences
and scientists, with your open
access and freedom, than
almost any other.
I can tell you, you have been
an inspiration for my large
team of scientists.
We are probably the first team
in a very competitive,
contentious field that have
completely opened access to
these fossils.
Any scientist can look at these
fossils at any time,
published or unpublished.
And a lot of that is due
to the inspiration that
organizations like yours have
done, in the very sense that
it was the free access to
information that in fact was
very much responsible
in the beginning,
for making this discovery.
Thank you very much.
So yeah, how I would balance
that sort of thing is I don't.
I literally have not spent more
than a minute and a half
at those other sites.
And I didn't have a
nine-year-old with me when I
went back to them.
But what I'm doing now is
trying to train the next
generation of explorers.
We need to get people
out of the labs.
We have done a tremendous job
of training, for the last 30
to 40 years, laboratory
scientists.
We're great at analyzing
the small amounts
of material I have.
What we have not trained is a
great deal of people with an
awareness that there's more out
there to be discovered.
In fact, in 2000, a major
scientist in the field,
actually from this particular
region of the world, said
there were no new fossil sites
to be discovered on the
continent of Africa.
We had pretty much found
the entire trend.
Something like this
proves that wrong.
That also, though, engendered
a spirit of a lack of
exploration and discovery
in our field
that we need to kill.
It needs to be killed.
Things like this will kill it.
But we're actually going to
begin training, deliberately,
young explorers.
We're building exploration
academies that train not only
people in paleontology
but all the fields.
Because if it's true
in my field, it's
true in your field.
I just think it's right
next to a city.
The fact is the discoveries
happened there.
Like many discoveries, what
that does is become this
magnet for people to go back.
Because we love safety,
don't we?
If he found it here, I'm going
to start in the cave right
next to it.
Then I'm going to start in
the one just out of that.
These dolomitic limestones cover
huge regions of Africa.
You can find them in Zimbabwe,
Mozambique, Zambia, Angola,
Uganda, the Congo, huge
regions of Africa--
unexplored.
You can find in Eastern
Europe.
You can find them in India.
You can find them in China.
I'm working with the
Chinese now.
I'm looking at building
exploration, instead of just
working in sites that were found
by Westerners in the
1920s and 1930s.
We need to just get out there.
It's not going to
be a miracle.
It's just going to be that
we haven't been looking.
I know it looks like bone.
It's not bone.
It has been replaced.
What you're seeing here in
this particular sense,
although the preservation is
very good, the kind of
yellowish color is actually due
to calcium phosphate, a
large amount of phosphatic
materials from bat guano and
things replacing into it.
It's been replaced heavily by
calcium carbonate, manganese,
magnesium, and other minerals.
That's not bone.
The teeth are absolutely the
same teeth that were in their
mouth, interestingly.
Because it's already a
fossil in your mouth.
It's a hard substance.
However, having said
that, there is
organic trace in this.
And because of the
extraordinarily interesting
way in which it was preserved,
very suddenly, very quickly,
it has preserved
very surprising
levels of organic material.
And that opens up potentials of
exploration that are really
quite exciting.
We think it was probably
almost like a sinkhole
environment, but almost
like a pitcher plant.
And it probably had
water in it.
Well, they were preserved
in water.
So we know it had water
in the bottom of it.
And we probably think that all
of these animals were going
after water.
Water is about the only thing
in the world that a animal
will take a life or
death risk for.
We tend to forget, because we're
nice and civilized, how
important water is.
But if I put you on a 30-meter
platform that you couldn't
reach the pole underneath, and
I put you up there with all
the water you could drink, I
could come back in two weeks
and there'd be a skinny you,
sitting alive up on top of
that platform.
If I put you up on that platform
with non-liquid
foods, and I put a glass of
water at the bottom--
48 hours.
You might make it 72, before
I'd find your body at the
bottom of it.
And these all seemed
to have indications
of breaks and falls.
They were desperately trying
to get down there.
And they wouldn't
do it for food.
You're mixing animals--
carnivores, herbivores,
omnivores--
together, into this strange
mix of things.
And the only thing that
unifies them is water.
That's precisely what was
happening when I found those
600 or so other sites.
I learned where the direction
of flow would be along fault
lines and such as that.
So I didn't always have to see a
clean cluster of trees, like
I described to you.
I was finding them also
without that.
It's also the kind of thing that
we're now applying and we
can put into computers and
programs to actually do that
in areas that we haven't
explored yet.
Once we ground truth a little
bit, we can find these
patterns and actually use
them to find more.
That's going to offer an
explosive rate of discovery, I
think, in the next decades.
In this particular case, there
isn't a cave, although there
may be a cave underneath.
We're about to do
ground-penetrating radar.
As you move up the hill, there
are lots of real caves in the
ones that you would think of.
And some hold fossils,
some don't.
It's really like-- imagine
a block of Swiss cheese.
And imagine the holes you can't
see are real caves.
And the ones where the cheese
is cut are these.
And they've been infilled
by various materials.
So some of them are
little holes.
Some of them are big holes.
And it depends on the luck
of where you are at that
particular slice, on the form
and shape of that hole,
although all of them
were at one time a
cavity within the Earth.
We're going in that direction.
We're using things.
We're working with the
[? SAFARI ?] program, with the
U-2 fly-overs, that look at
things like spectral imaging
and all that.
We're looking at magnetics.
We're looking at all kinds
of ways to establish the
existence of these.
What it will require, though,
is another generation of
strong fieldwork, where you're
getting out and ground
truthing the existence of these
and then relaying it
back to these enormous and
fantastic data sets that we're
accumulating.
That's why things like Google
Earth, as it improves, and the
quality of that are
so important.
Because it's going to launch
this resource base for the
future of fossils.
You may very well see a
situation very, very shortly
that these are fast becoming
not the rare,
sought-after objects.
They'll still be sought after.
But they may not be rare.
If you'd asked me that three
or four years ago, I would
have waffled on about
well, they
lived in broken woodlands.
And we take the animals
and we--
the beauty of this site is it
collected over a period of
probably a few weeks to, at
most, a couple of months the
entirety of the assemblage.
We're finding organic remains,
plant remains, seeds.
We have things like fetuses of
antelopes inside of their
mothers, inside of this.
We're going to give you the time
of year within a couple
of weeks that this happened.
We're also going to give you a
texture of environment that's
unprecedented.
You're going to see a real
environment reconstructed.
I'm not going to tell you what
that is right now, because
we're building this
super-accurate picture.
And anything I tell you would
in fact just be a disservice
to the quality of
the information.
We will know.
I can reveal this, that we just
recently-- because we
were scanning with these
high-resolution scanners,
scanning the blocks-- we found
out that the blocks themselves
are not rock in the
way we thought.
They're actually comprised
of organic material
like leaves and seeds.
We'd been destroying the very
evidence we had always been
looking for of the actual
environment.
And they're buried in it.
And we were taking it away in
order to figure out what the
environment was that
they lived in.
AUDIENCE: It's kind
of like peat.
LEE BERGER: Yeah.
But of course, it would be.
Imagine the bottom of a cave,
with trees and a world out.
Every time it rains, that
material gets washed in.
Leaves fall in, an
animal drops in.
It's an organic compost,
if you will.
That's exactly what's
in the bottom.
You mix a high degree of calcium
carbonate coming out
of the dolomitic limestones.
The water is supersaturated
in calcium carbonate.
Add some fine silts into that.
It is a perfect environment
for fossilization.
We are hoping so.
We're hoping that we will be the
generation of scientists
that minimizes the destruction
of material.
If I'd had even a portion of the
rocks that were attached
to some of the great fossils,
like the Taung child or Lucy,
or these things, we could do
so much now with them.
We could date them.
We can't date them anymore,
because that
material has been removed.
We could tell the environments
and that sort of thing.
We have recognized that.
And we're the first team that's
backing off of that
material and saying, no, first
we've got to push technology.
So this large block that my
wife, Jackie, discovered has
got this skeleton in it.
And I'm not letting it be
prepared, even though there
are bones in there that we have
never seen in the history
of searching for human origins,
complete femurs and stuff.
I'm making them push the
technology before I will touch
that, to try and extract them.
To try and make programs that
will actually see into this
and extract them in a quality
that we can use.
Because it might be the last
time this happens.
And if we don't invent that
technology, who's
going to invent it?
And you need something big
enough to drive the kind of
R&D that it takes to push the
field in a direction.
And this is big enough.
Excellent question.
Next?
We, as you might imagine, are
expending every effort,
working with the very
finest labs in the
world who work on that.
Because it's impossible.
There will be no
2-million-year-old DNA.
Of course, there won't.
However, we have certain things
preserved that may give
signals that things like amino
acids were preserved.
And if amino acids
were preserved,
you might have proteins.
So good question.
That's probably a good
one to end on.
Thank you very much, everyone,
for your attention.